Kylie Jenner is sad she never went to
prom plus we're backstage with Mariah
Carey and her man and we caught them
take a test hit I and G hey guys this is
the daily Jenny
I'm Jenny direct oh and buy a raise of
hands who went to prom who wishes they
didn't well Kylie Jenner wishes she did
Kylie never got to go to her prom and we
know it because the girl has virtually
grown up in front of the cameras and now
the 19 year old is explaining why she
never got her own high school fairy tale
in this sneak peak of life of Kylie wait
why did you go to prom oh it was really
sad actually I had to unfollow all my
friends that I went to school it
probably all thought I hated them but I
just couldn't see it you know because
they were always Toaster toes and they
are always the prom knows I can't see it
opening me sad
look I had a blast on my prom a girl you
are flying so you let kids collect your
coins and move south go thankfully for
you Kylie you'll finally get a shot I'd
go into prom because in the premiere
episode of her new spin-off show life of
Kylie the makeup mogul plots to surprise
a fan named Albert
here's formal dance that airs Sunday on
E but moving on to Mariah Carey she
touched down on the iconic Hollywood
Bowl here in Los Angeles last night Mimi
had three costume changes 12 songs and
one perfect man how do I know this
because et was backstage and our cameras
caught this sweet moment between Mimi
and her on-again off-again boyfriend
dancer / creative director Bryan Tanaka
he kisses her cheek and then sneaks
another one on the lips
Bryan even had even more to gush about
when I called Lee still snagged them for
a quick interview backstage what do you
love the most about touring and
performing with Mimi just being with her
it's to share a passion of performing
and music and just you know just just
sharing such a special moment and a
special thing that we both cherish so
much
you know it's just doing it together now
this is the part where I would normally
rate them on the John and Chrissy scale
of relationshipgoals but you know what
i'ma let you guys decide that come on on
a scale from one to John Legend and
Chrissy Teigen
where do Riya and Bryan land meanwhile
Mariah and Lionel Richie's all the hits
tour continues through September and as
you guys know Lionel is rumoured to be a
new judge on American Idol something
Mariah knows all too well
speaking of Lionel it's he is said to be
joining American Idol have you heard
this and do you have any advice for I
have not I would say don't do it no
longer kidding if you want to do it
that'll be great if you think the key B
I think you'd be really good at it do
you think you'd be they just are trying
to spoil me when I went on there so yeah
that's why the only reason I say that
but well Katy Perry's on it it's time it
should be a bit more than ever Liars
should we do - yeah I kind of love that
low-key Idol shade all right moving on
from the Queen diva - the professor of
thug anomic 'some self his name is John
state that's right John Cena has been
tapped to start in the transformer
spin-off bumblebee because we need more
Transformers movies Hollywood Reporter
first broke the casting news John will
star opposite pitch perfect 3 star
Hailee Steinfeld in the lead movie is a
prequel to the Michael Bay films that
started in 2007 and will be directed by
Travis Knight who did the stop-motion
movie Google and the two strings last
year and can we just admit it is a good
time to be John Cena right now not only
is he one of the most famous WWE
wrestlers of all time he is entering his
40s with an engagement to fellow
wrestler Nikki Bella plus a record-tying
16th World Championship belt another
season of his television show American
grit and now a starring role in a major
Hollywood franchise call me crazy but
because the man who has already earned
raised and trained wreck and sisters
beheaded for the same kind of crossover
stardom as his former WrestleMania
opponent bring the rock Johnson okay it
doesn't matter what you think
[Music]
now if you need of Cena fix he's
wrestling schinsky Nakamura on Smackdown
on USA
two nights for a chance to appear in the
main event title match at SummerSlam
which if he wins means Cena would become
the most decorated wrestler of all time
and I just said a whole lot of words
that I'm not a hundred percent sure what
they need in other sports news beyonce
is reportedly interested in buying a
stake in her hometown team the Houston
Rockets
I apologize me have been overdue for
Beyonce mentioned so there it is folks
but enough sports talk let's discuss a
bachelorette luckily our batch bail or
demos back of all the drums I went down
on the men tell all last night I
apologize for yelling please not yelling
at me girl last night reunions had it
all shouting matches tears how would you
describe it in one sentence in the words
of Chris Harrison it was the most
dramatic mental all of all time okay was
it maybe the most dramatic but it did
have a major discussion that mental all
has never really had before racism oh
well I know you spoke with the guys
about Lee you're talking about Lee after
the taping what's the group consensus do
we hate him um you know these guys
really trading with kid gloves I think
even more so than he deserves
they were really focused on push and
love his way and on helping him learn
learn about since in other ways that he
was thinking but the question is did
they believe Lee's apology I asked all
of them that question did they think he
was really so sorry their answers are
very interesting I love that while you
guys clearly Lauren has so much more to
say on all this in a brand spanking new
episode of roses and Rosie I've been
practicing you bought me two YouTube
channel now if you like what you see
then you should subscribe to our YouTube
channel because they have a little
something for everybody
I forgive you for yelling it I'm sorry
again thank you bye are you guys is
always sick with Entertainment Tonight
and et online.com
we've got you covered on all things
Hollywood by I'm going to decide